well what a night joining us now is the
chairman of the conservative party
oliver dad and very good morning hello
good morning
uh let's start by talking about last
night if we may um an absolute dropping
wasn't it what went wrong
well voters in north shropshire were fed
up and they gave us a kicking
and i think they wanted to send us a
message and i want to say as chairman of
the conservative party we've heard that
loud and clear
we need to get on with delivering the
job and that's precisely what we're
doing for example with the booster
program to deal with its own macron
variant we've administered over 700 000
vaccines just yesterday i would though
say that these are quite unique
circumstances
and in a by-election like this you would
expect the opposition party of the
labour party to be surging they were
strong second and in fact they're
sinking but it wasn't normal by election
dynamics was it you talk about special
circumstances but really um you've
gifted this to the lib dems and you say
that they sent you a message the voters
there what is the message that you're
receiving and is it an endorsement do
you think of your leader well voters are
clearly fed up and they want us to get
on with the job and focus on the job and
our job as a government particularly at
a time of crisis like this is to make
sure we're focused on the core
priorities number one is to get on with
delivering the booster program that's
the way we stay open and we maintain
normal life during this very difficult
period the prime minister's put turbo
boosters under that and we've had over
700 000
boosters administered the primary on the
economy we've we've got some of the
lowest unemployment since before the
crisis but that's where our focus isn't
about the booster jab is it this is a
referendum on the prime minister
effectively is he still an electoral
asset for the conservatives yes i think
the prime minister is an electoral asset
for the conservative party and i'll tell
you why just take the three really big
calls we've faced get brexit done he's
delivered on it we've delivered the
fastest people would say they're not
scientists we've delivered the fastest
booster program
in the world twice over and we've seen
the economy through this terrible period
with unemployment lower than when we
entered so i think actually on the big
calls the prime minister has the vision
and the direction to get us through this
difficult period a lot of the red wall
tories they were going to be worried
aren't they and any tory indeed with a
slim majority they're going to be
worried about their seats you've got a
problem
well
we see results like this mid-term it's
it's the case it happens time and time
again you know between 1989 and 2014 we
didn't win a single by-election in
government we lost brexit to the liberal
democrats before the 2019 election we
won it back if the liberal democrats did
as well in by-elections uh in general
elections they don't buy elections
they've been in power for the past 50
years it is the case that people have
sent us a message we've heard that
message but i wouldn't extrapolate too
much through to the general so mumblings
about no confidence in the prime
minister are conversations being had
behind closed doors and letters being
written
i have no idea where the letters are are
being written but i have every
confidence the prime minister has the
leadership to see us through this period
and i think
he he has shown whether it's in relation
to getting brexit down or this latest
record-beating booster campaign that
he's got that drive and determination
again we'll come on to the booster
campaign i know you're clearly very keen
to talk about it more stories though
today uh in the day's papers your leader
himself the prime minister is accused of
attending a party at number 10 during
the first lockdown your comments on that
please well i understand that this was a
meeting that took place in the garden
actually it was the case at the time if
you're going to have a meeting you're
better off having it outside because of
the the fresh air and and ventilation so
will questions be asked will there be an
investigation into that well i've seen
the the account given by by downing
street that this there was a meeting
that took place and it took place
outside i think that was a perfectly
appropriate and unreasonable
there had been a press conference
previously
and it was perfectly reasonable to have
the meeting afterwards outside so will
simon case be looking into the details
of that one as well i don't think
there's a need for the cabinet secretary
to look into this one because the the
circumstance appear to be pretty clear
um cchq we understand again from the
papers that police are quizzing two
people um about that party that took
place there with sean bailey is it right
that police are quizzing two people that
were there at cchq and they're not
looking into what happened at the
various parties that are being alleged
at number 10.
well you wouldn't expect me as a cabinet
minister to comment on the operationally
independent metropolitan police but in
respect of the
completely unauthorized party that took
place
at conservative hq by the london mayoral
campaign it was appalling it was wrong
it should never have happened and the
people involved have been punished okay
let's uh let's move on another front
page that i don't think you'll like the
look of uh it's beginning to look a lot
like christmas terrible pun there
but the idea is that's the direction of
travel are we looking at more
restrictions ahead of christmas
well these are very difficult times and
we've seen with this surge of omicron
doubling almost every two days we're
having to take very difficult decisions
and i think anyone that that pretends
that this is simple or straightforward
is pretending however i do think right
now we have got the balance right the
key thing is the booster if you can can
you come back to the resolution this is
a very important this is a very
important point though about the booster
because it's only if people get that
booster that we can continue with this
kind of freedoms that we have now it
gives you 75
protection against it probably more
against hospitalization that is the
plank on which we're building our
strategy um wales is bringing in new
restrictions scotland has gone further
um why are we always a step behind and
even the queen has cancelled her
christmas parties shouldn't the
messaging be clearer
well the message is clear that people
need to be sensible and cautious but
because of the vaccine because of the
booster we are confident that we can
have restrictions as they stand at the
moment alongside the further mask
wearing and so on
it's because of the strength of that
booster and that's why it's essential
that we keep getting that booster into
people's arms and we've had record
success with that yesterday with over
700 000 administered i think that is the
correct and balanced approach all right
less than what what is targeted though
at a million you are asking people to
choose effectively though aren't you
between
the advice being given by the chief
medical officer professor chris witte
and the government very mixed messaging
there but it appears that those as
though people's trust is going with the
medical professionals we've seen the
cancellations we've seen a real drop off
in people using public transport uh
they're not trusting the government on
this
well chris whitty with whom you might
imagine i speak frequently prime
minister cabinet and i are all in
agreement and the single best thing we
can do in this situation is to get the
booster rolled out as rapidly as
possible we made that big call back in
the summer to buy the pfizer modern
another big call by the prime minister
that is very effective against this new
omicron variant
we're saying to everyone get your
booster if you get your booster we can
build back up that wall of defense and
continue with life as it was before just
one last question about uh chris whitty
reports in the papers that he's under
fire from tory mps for effectively
freelancing and advising people in a way
that doesn't accord with what the
government is saying is your party at
war with the cmo well i have a great
deal of respect for for chris whitty and
i think we should respect his integrity
and independence as an advisor of course
advisors adviser and ministers decide
and are accountable for the strategy of
off the back of that and i know that
these are difficult times and people
have what do you think
were you personally disappointed with
his intervention at the press conference
i think it's perfectly appropriate for
chris witte to advise the government
which is exactly what he has done but is
equally perfectly appropriate for the
government to make decisions off the
back of that and that's what we've done
with this strategy the core part of
which is the boost campaign i'm sorry to
keep on talking about it but it is so
essential that people get that boost one
other thing i want to talk to you about
before we get on to boosters a business
community crying out for support the
chancellor was swallowing around in
california what is going on is there any
more support for businesses well the
chancellor certainly wasn't spawning
around the chancellor was out in the
united states representing the united
kingdom meeting with leading businesses
in the united states he's also been in
constant contact for example with the
hospitality industry and the the prime
minister we have demonstrated time and
time again that we will stand behind
business when they need that support for
example when i was culture secretary i
remember when lockdown started i was
warned that we could lose a third of
football clubs two-thirds of our
cultural institutions thanks to the
record cultural recovery fund two
billion pounds we've preserved almost
all of them there's money there there's
money in relation to to business right
now i know you say that
forgive me for interrupting mr dowden um
i know you say he's meeting with
businesses in america it's very
important businesses say that they're
going to go to the wall over christmas
here they say where is he he should be
meeting with us he didn't show up to a
round table yesterday he also says that
existing support is enough but the
businesses say they won't survive
through christmas so what's going to
happen is is there any hope of more
support for them
well the chancellor is is returning to
the united kingdom to today i i
understand
if you look at the kind of support
that's available take the business rate
really through to spring that will mean
that businesses are paying a quarter of
the business rates they would normally
pay for that's why we've cut v80 and
kept vat cut at 12 and a half percent
there's also over a quarter of a billion
pounds still with local authorities that
could go to support businesses and i
know the chancellor is working with them
to get that money out so we have proven
that we'll put the resources in and we
will support those businesses and i know
the chancellor's committed to doing that
all right but no new money as far as you
know at the moment as you sit here
we have already put support in place of
course we watch this hour by hour
day by day and i know the chancellor is
very closely engaged but at the moment
we have appropriate supports in place
all right oliver dowden thank you very
much for coming in to see us at sky news
have a great christmas